I spent 100 hours researching the wackiest
theories in One Piece - like the theory that
this dude is Luffy’s mother [Show Crocodile],
or the theory Luffy might die at the end of
even more ridiculous than the mangaka Oda-Sensei
when they try to figure out what crazy plot
twist is coming next!
But here’s an absurd sounding theory that…might
actually make sense?
The first rival devil fruit user that Luffy
ever fought against was Buggy the Clown all
the way back in the beginning chapters of
One Piece.
Buggy the Chop-Chop fruit user was revealed
to have known Luffy’s mentor Shanks as a
child and even served alongside him as a cabin
boy on Gol D. Roger the pirate king’s
ship!
Throughout the whole series, as Luffy has
fought tooth and nail to get stronger, Buggy
has been failing upwards.
After Luffy teamed up with him to break out
of the prison Impel Down, Buggy was named
a Warlord of the Sea by the World Government.
And now he’s even become an Emperor of the
Sea!
But if Buggy keeps accidentally stumbling
into higher and higher positions in the pirate
world, there’s only one more place to go
after being named a Yonkou.
That’s right - even though Luffy will be
the one to deserve the title of pirate king,
is it possible that the world will recognize
Buggy as the pirate king first??
**#2 - Portgas D. Rouge ate the Gomu-Gomu
no Mi**
In all my research, though, that theory doesn’t
even come close to the craziest.
That’s right - there are ten more theories
even crazier than Buggy becoming King of the
Pirates!
This next one deals with who had Luffy’s
Gomu-Gomu no Mi before Luffy did.
Lots of people assumed for a long time that
it must have been Roger.
After all, Roger shares a dream with Luffy,
he was the original owner of the Straw Hat,
and has a really similar personality to Luffy.
So it would only make sense if Roger even
had the Gomu-Gomu no Mi.
But this theory says it’s not Roger at all,
but Portgas D. Rouge who previously had this
rubber power.
For those of you who need a reminder, Rouge
is Luffy’s brother Ace’s mother.
She’s notable for having been pregnant with
Ace for 2 years before giving birth.
Since the government was rounding up any baby
that could have been Roger’s offspring,
she somehow kept Ace in her womb for fifteen
extra months.
How is this possible?
Well, according to this theory, she did it
because she had a….really stretchy uterus?
Now I know that Oda’s series isn’t exactly
scientifically accurate, especially when it
comes to the medical field…but this one
seems like a “stretch” in more ways than
one.
**#3 - The fight against the Blackbeard Pirates
will be a Davy Back Fight**
Now we all know that Goda is a master of foreshadowing.
Therefore he’d never put anything in his
series that wasn’t relevant!
So what was with the Davy Back Fight arc where
the Straw Hats competed with Foxy on Long
Ring Long Land?
It’s an arc so disliked by some fans that
some people mistakenly think it’s filler!
But nope, this is a canon manga arc.
So will Davy Back Fights become important
again?
Well, some people think that it will come
back in a big way when the Straw Hats finally
go head on against the Blackbeard Pirates!
Every One Piece theorist out there has their
dream matchups of which Straw Hat will fight
which Blackbeard Pirate - so imagine the God
Tier Troll that Oda could pull when Marshall
D. Teach challenges Luffy to this high-stakes,
ridiculous game!
**#4 - The Thousand Sunny is Pluton**
Cyborg Franky, the shipwright of the Straw
Hats, built the Thousand Sunny after their
old ship the Going Merry finally had to be
retired after being terribly damaged in many
voyages.
But before he built this ship, it was revealed
that Franky had hidden the blueprints to the
Ancient Weapon Pluton, an all-powerful warship,
for decades.
He even went to far as to burn the blueprints
to protect them from falling into the hands
of the World Government.
But with his technological genius, what if
he transferred part of the designs into his
dream ship?
Is The Thousand Sunny hiding some crazy weaponry?
Is Oda finally going to give us the ship-to-ship
combat we’ve always dreamed of??
**#5 - Imu and the Gorosei are immortal because
of the immortality surgery**
Now these next three theories are all related
and they deal with one of the most theorized
about powers in all of One Piece.
In Dressrosa, Donquixote Doflamingo revealed
a secret power of the Ope-Ope no Mi - the
fruit used by Trafalgar Law.
Apparently the fruit’s Immortality Surgery
can sacrifice the user’s life in order to
grant someone immortality.
Dofllamingo wanted Law to use the power on
him, but thankfully Luffy saved the day and
defeated the warlord.
Viewers have noticed, though, that a certain
set of characters always appear to be the
same age even when they appear in flashbacks.
Usually when we flashback 20 years or so to
see younger versions of Rayleigh or Garp or
whatever other character, it’s very clear
that they’ve aged.
However, the Five Elder Stars always appear
to look exactly the same.
We can also guess that the same is true for
the secret leader of the World Government,
Imu-Sama.
Did several previous users of the Ope-Ope
no Mi sacrifice themselves to give the rulers
of the government everlasting life?
If so, it would make sense that Doflamingo,
a Celestial Dragon, would know about the power.
**#6.
Law will make Luffy immortal with the surgery**
Law having this crazy power at all, though,
begs the question: Who’s he going to use
the Immortality Surgery on?
It would be a crime against storytelling to
introduce such an earth-shattering power and
have it never be relevant to the story!
Well, one obvious person for him to use it
on would be Straw Hat Luffy himself.
Ever since the time skip, Law has been Luffy’s
greatest ally in the ongoing conflict against
Doflamingo, Kaidou, and Big Mom.
And while the two are rivals for the One Piece,
one could definitely imagine a scenario where
Luffy’s life is threatened, so Law sacrifices
himself to save his ally.
It would be absolutely heart wrenching, and
possibly the saddest death in the entire series.
After all, we’ve spent a lot more time with
Law than we ever did with Ace or Whitebeard.
What do you think?
After all the fake out deaths we’ve had,
do you think Oda would be bold enough to kill
off a fan favorite like Law??
**#7 - Luffy Will Die**
And speaking of killing off characters, here’s
the most controversial one Oda could possibly
kill.
At the end of the series, will Luffy die?
Let’s say that Law doesn’t make the ultimate
sacrifice to make Luffy immortal…we hate
to say it, but Luffy has some death flags.
First off, he wants to be the pirate king.
And we all know what happened to the last
pirate king…a little thing called public
execution.
Maybe Luffy’s death will be what sets off
a brand new pirate era.
Secondly, though, just think of all the time
that it’s been hinted that Luffy is shortening
his life span.
When he uses Gear 2 for the first time in
Enies Lobby, CP9 hints that such a technique
would be shortening his life overall.
When he received hormone treatments from Ivankov,
Iva also warned that it would take years off
his life.
Recently during the Kaidou fight, after using
Gear 5 for a while, Luffy appeared to transform
into an elderly man temporarily.
Just how much lifespan does Luffy have left
to shorten??
**#8 - Crocodile is Luffy’s Mom**
Ah, we’re finally back to CrocoMom - the
theory we hinted at the beginning of the video.
But wait a minute, this is only #8 of 11 theories!
You mean there are 3 more theories even wilder
than this?
Oh yeah, so you’ll just have to stay tuned.
But first - here’s CrocoMom.
Now this is one of the longest running, most
memeified, and weirdly believable theories
in the entire fanbase.
When Luffy helped Crocodile and co.
break out of Impel Down, Emporio Ivankov convinced
this former warlord to be on his best behavior
by holding some deep dark secret over him.
Given that the person who knows Croc’s secret
is Ivankov, who can notably change peoples’
genders with their hormone fruit, it’s heavily
speculated that Crocodile was actually born
a woman and asked Iva to turn into a man.
This fan theory takes this speculation one
step further, though, and suggests that not
only was Crocodile a woman.
She’s actually Luffy’s mom.
After all, Oda has stated that Luffy’s mom
is a character he’s drawn before…so this
guess seems as good as any!
**#9 -. The crew will go to the Moon**
For our final three One Piece theories you
didn’t know existed, we have theories about
the One Piece itself.
Theory #9 is that the One Piece isn’t in
the Grand Line at all…it’s on the moon!
Listen, I promise this has more to it than
you think!
If you’re an anime only watcher, you might
not realize just how important the moon is
to the story of One Piece.
In the manga, Oda often uses his cover pages
to tell side stories about what characters
are up to around the world.
After Skypiea, we got to see Enel fulfill
his dream of traveling to “Fairy Vearth”
AKA the moon.
What was shocking was that the moon was actually
inhabited!
Enel ran into alien Space Pirates and an army
of automatons.
He even found the ruins of an ancient civilization
that would appear to depict the winged races
of the Sky Island together with images of
the ancient weapons.
If the moon is connected to some mysterious
ancient civilization, could it be possible
that the greatest treasure - the One Piece
- is there too?
**10.
The One Piece is the friends we made along
the way**
Another popular One Piece theory?
It’s nothing.
There is no treasure at all.
Now this theory is practically as old as the
entire series, with fans constantly joking
that the One Piece would be “the adventure
itself” or “the friends we made along
the way.”
Oda has stated that the One Piece is a physical
treasure.
But knowing how hard Oda can troll, we wouldn’t
put it past him for that physical treasure
to be a written note from Roger that says…that
the real treasure is friendship.
I know a few fans who would probably drop
the series if this were true…but the joke
would be on them because the series would
already be over.
But I highly doubt Oda would let us down - instead
the One Piece treasure will probably be something
completely awesome.
Something like:
**11.
Luffy will destroy the red line**
The One Piece is Luffy destroying the red
line - the massive continent that circles
the globe and separates the planet into four
distinct oceans.
But wait - how is destroying the red line
a treasure?
Well, this would very literally make the world
into “one piece” by uniting all four oceans
into one.
A couple big hints for this theory are that
Marie Jois, the capital of the world government,
is located on top of the Red Line.
If Luffy ends up going to war against the
World Government and takes the fight to them,
destroying Pangea Castle might result in destroying
the Red Line, too.
In addition, when the crew was on Fishman
Island, the fortune teller Madame Sharly prophesied
that Luffy would destroy the island.
And Fishman Island happens to be located beneath
the Red Line, directly below Marie Jois.
We also have hints such as the whale Laboon,
the first character we met in the Grand Line,
repeatedly bashing his head against the Red
Line, trying to destroy it.
Bringing down the Red Line would mean uniting
the world and bringing the people together
into one people - One Piece.
**Conclusion**
These were just 11 of the wildest One Piece
theories that I found after doing tons and
tons of research.
I just discussed this one about Oars being
the original Joy Boy, that will blow your
mind.
So if you have some more time, go check it
out here.